i have to parlay off a kilroy's yeah you
know we talked about soul-crushing
service jobs right i think medieval
times oh yeah may take the case okay so
tell me about it yeah first of all you
know it was well wait wait lay some
groundwork like what is it yeah people
that don't live in l.a uh not medieval
times it's not a chain is it
it's a chain what it's in canada
no it's around oh okay um how many
locations is medieval times yeah look
that up
uh
let us explain so americans have this
thing
okay we got one in georgia buena park
bueno park where we were at okay next to
jersey texas there's one in schaumburg
of course there's one in schaumburg
myrtle beach of course you know that
[ __ ] that one probably goes off
see it does you've been there it does
you've been there oh yeah to the myrtle
beach
medieval times this is what i needed
like as in you've been there more than
once see this is what i needed to hear i
bet scottsdale one goes crazy too oh
dude everything in scottsdale goes crazy
what's it like luke the one in myrtle
beach it's been a long time since i've
been but yeah you can't say that and the
last time you went with seven of course
it went off yeah you know yeah it was
incredible for a seven-year-old so we
went to the buena park one and it's it's
uh they trick you because it's next to a
gigantic porto so they they they make
you think like ah get some portos and
then go into the wait there's a there's
a porto's there right next to the like
the chicago place no no next to the
buena park medieval times that we went
to gotcha it's like the biggest porto's
i've ever seen so we get there i have
some portals i'm like i'm ready we go in
to me to medieval times now for those of
you that don't know the the pinnacle
moment of this
show is they joust
and being accepted so it's a it's a show
it's a show but can you eat there oh
yeah but you had food before yeah
because i'm a hungry boy okay so you
also you did a bang bang yeah okay yeah
and is it like giant turkey legs and
like renaissance fairy oh i will we will
get into it and you will be
yeah so i just need to set the stage as
experienced sword fighters ourselves
as people who have done this for real
you know i'm kind of going in with a
different mindset right because you're
kind of like i'm analyzing technique
yeah we've been in that ring before oh
yeah okay we know what it's like to be
on that stage so uh we go in and i don't
know what i'm expecting but i'm
forgetting that there's horses and the
first thing that hits you when you walk
into the arena
is it smells like [ __ ]
and to their credit they are pumping a
massive ac system in there okay and it's
doing a good job of like masking it okay
it's funny like you you catch the waves
of horseshit like every other second
right so as you're walking your seat
you're like oh wait
oh what is though oh never mind oh yeah
oh
yeah
oh gross oh never mind i lost it
do you smell that never mind it's gone
no you smell that yeah yeah literally
and then it was funny watching because i
was at the back of the group and it was
funny watching everyone in front like
slowly turn their heads backwards
when you walk in they assign you because
there's going to be
like eight knights okay that are gonna
fight okay and one of them's gonna win
right
and so they assign you a night when
you're going in so we get the green
night we're like hell yeah we are some
of the only adults here can you bet huh
can you bet on it see
this is why you should own one
[Laughter]
we should franchise one uh i think we
definitely should
no but what you can do is you can get um
a royal margarita okay okay
but we were kind of late it was pretty
early we got a matinee show so no one is
like so
sorry again interrupt yeah why did you
go we thought it would be especially
during the day we thought it'd be like a
funny ironic thing where it was like
sort of like ah let's it'll be stupid
the show's what like an hour yeah it'll
probably be funny okay
we just have like a quick like like
almost like watching a bad movie right i
understand that completely and how far
is buena park uh on a sunday it's like
40 minutes okay
yeah and it's like all right that bad
yeah you go maybe drink a little bit
like it could be stupid
what whatever so we get there and uh
we're kind of late we skip the drinks
you know because you can get one at your
seat now here's the thing when you buy a
ticket to medieval times your meal is
it's just one meal and it's funny
because when you walk in they say do we
have any food allergies and i don't know
why they ask because it's if you were to
say like oh yeah i'm allergic to
this thing to be like oh
well there's no food
like there's like there's only three
things that they give you
and if you're allergic they don't have
anything else okay so it's basically
just to find out if you can eat or not
okay so uh
we get to our seats it smells like ass
show begins and this script bro is so
intense it's historically accurate
there's a [ __ ] on a horse who's
like
good nobles
and it's all like six-year-olds and can
i ask how many people were there dude it
was surprising a lot a lot of birthdays
right you know we had we had prince eric
princess ayala
prince and princess and what birthday
are we talking six are we talking five
seven nine
ten thirteen
uh we had prince andrew who had oh then
prince oh god
and also prince noel it was turning 32
hey i'm 22 man
okay so first of all there's one that
killed us because there was a honeymoon
celebrating day one of their honeymoon
at medieval times the midday show on
sunday we were like what
so then immediately after that was a kid
and they go uh congratulations to prince
michael for good grades
lena looks at me she goes good grace
what the [ __ ] are we doing and another
thanks to prince noel for doing the
dishes yeah yeah yeah i mean it's like
you didn't do a good job
happy birthday buddy
you know the best part was
uh her friend whose actual birthday was
that was like the bit i was like oh dude
we should go to medieval times for
birthday that'd be stupid it'd be funny
oh you actually did go there for a
birthday yeah elena's friend who bought
the tickets put it in the notes like yo
it's it's his birthday
they didn't
no way we did all the kids and not him i
want a dick yeah grown-ass man didn't
even get the shout out damn so then
that's that's the saddest thing yeah
literally like it's so much sadder to
have your name not read in that list and
you're kind of the guy is like i'm not
reading this [ __ ] like
you're like you're kind of hopeful too
exactly because you're like it'll be
funny right and then he just doesn't
even read it
oh man i really shouldn't have came yeah
yeah yeah you especially don't feel well
yeah so yeah the crowd is like
parents who are you know imprisoned to
their mistakes are you like cosplaying
as a deadbeat parent
because you keep going like monster
truck rallies like you keep going like
no no no no no where you just sit
amongst these parents who hate their
lives no i'm reliving or i'm getting the
experiences that i should have gotten as
an eight-year-old as an adult okay okay
you know i'm just catching up you're not
convincing alina not to have children
babe look at this could be us that's a
great point because that is a peripheral
observation and i will say
selfishly i do
do a little bit of magician
ship when we leave okay okay i i do make
a point to do that a bit of gas lighting
you bit a little bit of gas yeah when
the kids act like [ __ ] i always lean
over to her i'm like so glad we don't
have those
and i do do that and i consciously know
what i'm doing i think next week we
should hit chuck e cheese yeah what do
you think babe yeah that's it that's a
great observation so we're sitting there
and um the food starts to come out to my
original point uh with with kilroy's you
know those people that don't even look
you in the eyes this woman was like on
autopilot like in a way that she's like
living in a loop like she's full on npc
right we're a row of adults and she
walks by handing out the chicken she
goes
uh clear hands baby dragon uh here's
your baby dragon
your baby dragon
move your play please use your baby
dragon
uh just make way for baby dragon
that's the way that and this is your
baby dragon she gets to me everyone's
supposed to kind of lift up their plate
and i just i zoned out on the show and i
just didn't
and she had like a
she didn't know what to do because i
think she said clear your hands baby
dragon i just didn't and she just stood
there and she was hovering and i like
looked up at her and she's like
can you give me your plate i think it's
the first word she said outside of
her nine phrases
it's like the npc like broke the loop
[Laughter]
wait what she's calling you baby dragon
no she's handing oh sorry so she's so
she has like half of like a chicken a
small chicken wrapped up in foil and
they call that a baby drink they call it
baby dragon that's like and you're gonna
eat it yeah yeah like that's
okay so that's the reveal of dragons
it's the it's the driest yeah it is the
veal of dragon it's kind of like a
[ __ ] up joke it's not they give you a
certificate they're like this is a
dragon dragon was killed yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah this is the name of the
grown in general and the child yeah
it was raised in a cage and force-fed
really fatty foods yeah yeah no th this
is the driest chicken possible okay
eating it was a task that looks like it
[ __ ] slaps it looks that way it
definitely looks that way well let me
set the stage here okay okay sorry
because it's it's very important going
into this that the first thing you
receive is a piece of texas toast with
no cheese okay they give you this like
they slap they just kind of slap it down
on your plate just that one piece of
bread just a piece with butter barely
okay it's buttered ish and you're kind
of like okay yeah i don't it looks sad
right it's not really appetizing
and then you have this little ladle i
don't know what you'd call it it's like
a small pot and they give you dragon
soup that's what they call it
now this is the this is the highlight of
the show move your arm baby dragon come
baby dragon piss so when they come
around
to give you the baby dragon uh gloop
yeah they take it and they serve it out
of a [ __ ] thermos it is the most
and granted i'm sure
i'm sure kitchens do that but don't do
it in front of my face yeah i mean yeah
like dude they
take the thing and you can hear it
behind you
[Laughter]
just slopping out of the thermos
and you get it and i took a picture of
this [ __ ] and i'll send it to the thread
but um did you taste it [ __ ] no someone
in our group took a cause they don't
give you utensils so he took a little
and he goes it tastes like spaghetti
we got kyle i mean that's just straight
up that all that is is just tomato juice
yeah whatever
yeah so whatever so then they they give
you like this mushy corn they give you
this dry chicken i bit into the leg
there's no juice at all but here's the
[ __ ] best part of the show is
actually give you like this like i don't
even know what you call it they go
would you like a to-go bag
not a box
a bag
and i said no but i [ __ ] wish i said
yes cause what what did they bring you
like a ziploc yeah just like a ziploc
bag and a straw and you just throw it
all in